villepinte en banlieue parisienne
sylvain est propriétaire d'un
appartement acheté 80 mille euros situé
dans sept tours au 7e étage il ne loue
plus mais depuis quatre mois ce petit
entrepreneur est confronté à une
situation pour le moins inédite des
occupants se sont installés illégalement
dans son 4 pièces ils ont même apposé
leur nom sur la boîte aux lettres comme
si de rien n'était c'est pas le nom
ancien locataire ni lumière les liens
qu'on a je reconnais pas compte ici
c'est voilà c'est chez moi mais c'est
plus chez moi pour la troisième fois
avec son ami il va tenter de débloquer
la situation
il veut rencontrer ces faux locataires
pour discuter on est chez moi c'est mon
appartement
c'est à dire que là moi j'ai une clé qui
correspond absolument pas à la serrure
voilà et une sereine qui n'était pas la
porte c'est pas la même donc voilà c'est
la force a été changée tous assez neuf
ça a été changé la personne est là mais
elle va pas ouvrir
voilà je suis pas
c'est en venant récupérer du courrier
qu'il s'est aperçu que son logement
étaient occupés illégalement le temps
passe la porte reste close
désabusé quitte l'immeuble mais au
moment de partir surprise il tombe nez à
nez avec des policiers en civil qu'est
ce qui vous a appelé c'est moi le
propriétaire du logement
les squatteurs ont appelé la police
importuné par les tambourine man à leurs
portes de sylvain la situation est
ubuesque
ce propriétaire se retrouve dans la peau
d'un fauteur de troubles obligé de se
justifier
apparemment elle apparemment rien de
parler bonjour bonjour je rentre je
rentre pas chez vous vous inquiétez pas
un
je voulais juste vous parler c'est tout
je voulais juste vous parlez je suis pas
venu faire faire un et ce quand je
voulais juste lui parler gentiment lui
demander mon ciel comptait rester là
longtemps si voilà en france la loi est
claire
après 48 heures d'occupation illégale
d'un logement il est trop tard la police
ne peut plus déloger les squatters
le seul recours pour un propriétaire une
procédure judiciaire souvent
interminables quelques jours plus tard
nous retournons à villepinte pour
rencontrer les occupants illégaux de
l'appartement de sylvain
ce père de famille que nous appellerons
sadio s'est installé dans l'appartement
avec sa femme et leurs jumeaux l'été
dernier cette famille s'est accaparé ce
quatre pièces refait à neuf et tout
confort lancement en fait la salle en
combo blu ray ici sadio et en cdi dans
une agence de sécurité et gagne 1200
euros net par mois
malgré ces garanties impossible pour lui
de trouver un appartement
cela fait quatre ans qu'il attend un
logement social et r d'hôtel en hôtel
sincèrement arbres s'ils dorment ici
voilà
mais un jour par l'intermédiaire d'un
ami un homme lui fait une proposition
qu'il ne peut pas refuser un logement en
location
la wii la pomme on n'arrêtait pas de
tomber la crise parce que je ne crois
pas l'homme demande au père de famille
1000 euros pour simplement pouvoir
entrer dans l'appartement et moi dans le
calcul des jeux l'abonné mais le respect
ça louche non le problème c'est qu'il
s'agit en fait d'un faux bail rédigé par
un escroc qui a depuis disparu
c'est en tout cas ce qu'affirme sadio
mais à peine les cartons des balles et
sylvain le propriétaire des lieux
débarque à l'improviste
ce jour là la femme de sadio est seule à
la maison avec les enfants
la radio vous n'avez pas où est la porte
ils sont français la plupart quoi dire
daïra sylvain n'est pas seul trois
hommes n'accompagne et semble déterminé
il y les gars c'est moi dans koh vous
êtes très occupé dès ma maison il faut
des nazis il s'entraîne et il est entré
comme ça ils ont réussi à prendre le
bébé
ils sont mille et dvd offre une
tentative d'expulsion musclée selon
cette famille choquée elle appelle la
police à son arrivée sylvain et ses gros
bras ont eu le temps de quitter les
lieux le lendemain les pousses de sadio
se rend aux urgences pour faire
constater des traces de violence sur
l'un de ses enfants et sur elle-même et
dans la foulée elle engage un avocat
nous retrouvons sylvain le propriétaire
à son domicile principal
il admet s'être rendu chez ces
squatteurs et conteste formellement
avoir employé la manière forte
selon lui il n'y a eu aucune violence
l'avocate de la partie adverse a entamé
une procédure contre moi elle me
reproche des choses que j'ai parfaite
voilà j'ai pas envie d'en parler j'ai
une procédure je ne peux pas en parler
voilà point barre j'espère que
que cette histoire se réglera
le mieux possible pour tout le monde
terme et squatteurs qui sont victimes et
pour moi qui suis une victime aussi en
attendant ce qui le préoccupe ce sont
tous ces mois de loyer qu'il ne perçoit
plus pour l'instant je perds à peu près
dix mille euros depuis cette histoire de
squats
ça va être à mon avis avant le mois de
juin l'année prochaine ce sera pas réglé
imaginez vous combien ça va me coûter en
plus je vais évidemment certainement
devoir refaire des travaux
si un jour mais squatters sont expulsés
la bataille juridique de sylvain contre
ses occupants illégaux est loin d'être
gagné les procédures d'expulsion peuvent
durer des années
son histoire n'est pas un cas isolé
dans les grandes villes le marché de
l'immobilier et confronté à une nouvelle
forme de délinquance changement de porte
et des serrures à l'insu du propriétaire
faux bail des escrocs profitent de la
fragilité de familles précaires en leur
faisant miroiter un logement soit disant
vacants et parfois il suffit de quelques
jours d'absence pour qu'un propriétaire
se retrouve avec des occupants illégaux
à son propre domicile
madame nguyen possède un pavillon à
vitry sur seine en région parisienne
mais depuis une semaine elle habite chez
sa fille et son gendre
entrons en saut cette retraitée de 82
ans caractère bien trempé ne peut plus
rentrer chez elle vous n'êtes pas chez
vous en ce moment mais non qu'est ce qui
vous est arrivé chez plume maison je
vois les étangs j'ai laissé ça j'ai les
étrangers et chant rentrer chez moi
madame nguyen est elle aussi victime de
squatters lorsqu'elle rentre chez elle
après un mois d'hospitalisation la
vieille dame fait une étrange découverte
le cadenas du portail a été changé alain
son gendre décide de l'enjamber et tombe
sur une famille qui vient tout juste de
s'installer dans la maison
dans la première chambre à gauche ah oui
il y avait une personne avec un jeune
homme qui dormait de dans un champ après
même suivre avancé en face à l'intérieur
il y avait un couple dans le lit un coup
je n'en lis plus un berceau avec un bébé
voilà alors j'avais demandé de sortir
les intrus refusent de quitter les lieux
c'était il ya quelques jours à peine le
pavillon de madame nguyen est située
dans une rue tranquille de vitry sur
seine
elle a acheté il ya 40 ans lorsque nous
nous présentons sur place une jeune
femme nous ouvre le portillon
nous l'appellerons sofia elle a 21 ans
cela fait maintenant une semaine qu'elle
occupe les lieux elle commence par nous
raconter comment un homme de son
entourage l'a fait entrer dans cette
maison avait une chaîne et un cadenas
ici donc je me suis avait la clé du
cadenas ensuite bas je suis je suis allé
avec lui à bas jusque là la porte
d'entrée
quand sophien rencontre cet homme elle
vit à l'hôtel depuis des mois il veut
l'aider et lui propose une sous-location
que c'était la maison de sa tante et qu'
elle ne vivait plus parce qu'elle était
âgée et qu'elle pouvait plus entretenir
sa maison et du coup bas comme j'avais
parlé de mon problème de logement il m'a
ramené c'est ce soi-disant philanthrope
lui réclame une grosse somme d'argent
mais sofia ne travaille pas et nos vies
que du rsa
alors il m'avait demandé 3000 euros
j'avais pas les moyens alors il m'a fait
demain moitié prix quoi pour entrer ici
contre 1500 euros un droit d'entrée en
quelque sorte
il lui remet la clé du pavillon la jeune
femme ne souhaite pas nous en dire
davantage sur lui dans la maison
aucune trace des trois autres personnes
aperçues par le gendre de madame nguyen
quelques jours plus tôt sofia dit vivre
seule ici avec son bébé de 4 mois
vous sentez soin d'eux ici squatteuse
non mais c'était parce que j'avais dans
la tête quoi c'était quand je suis venu
ici je me suis dit que j'avais loué
enfin certes pas à pas légalement mais
que j'avais donné une somme pour pouvoir
y habiter cette jeune mère célibataire
refuse catégoriquement de quitter les
lieux ce soit
c'est son seul refuge au grand désespoir
de madame nguyen la propriétaire ce
matin toute la famille est sur le pied
de guerre
objectif déloger au plus vite la
squatteuse pour cela il lui faut un
maximum de documents
première étape se procurer un
justificatif de domicile auprès de son
fournisseur d'énergie
vous allez exclusive aux squatteurs
aujourd'hui tout de suite
même quand c'est après mais mes mots mes
documents tout de suite dehors les
squatteurs mais alors que l'employé
cherche le contraint elle va
s'apercevoir qu'un autre abonnement
vient d'être souscrit pour la maison de
madame nguyen sinh aussi surprenant que
cela puisse paraître
sofia la jeune mère célibataire a pu
elle aussi prendre un abonnement chez un
fournisseur d'énergie a besoin de bail
ou de contrats de location pour obtenir
un contrat d'électricité et donc un
justificatif de domicile pour madame
nguyen et ses proches
les choses se compliquent il faut faire
vite il décide de jouer le tout pour le
tout une direction le commissariat de
vitry sur seine
compte tenu de l'âge et de la santé
fragile de la grand mère la famille
espère que la police délogera la jeune
sofia même si elle occupe les lieux de
plus que de 48 heures c'est du moins ce
que la famille pense au bout de cinq
heures
le gendre et la fille de madame nguyen
sortent enfin du commissariat la
situation semble sans issue
la pression est trop forte la fille de
madame nguyen fait un malaise
obama
mais rebondissement une demi heure plus
tard
est ce la présence de notre caméra en
tout cas fait rarissime
les policiers décident finalement de
déloger la squatteuse sur ordre du
préfet l'expulsion a lieu alors que nous
sommes aux côtés de madame nguyen vais
rentrer chez vous oui voilà rentré chez
moi ce soir là après une semaine
d'angoise la vieille dame peut enfin
rentrer chez elle super je peux pas
c'est un rêve pour moi
la police leur a remis la clé de la
serrure changé à la va vite par les
occupants illégaux
la famille décide d'inspecter la maison
pièce par pièce un il a dû interrompre
leur manger il y a encore une heure
sofia et son bébé promener sans le
savoir leur dernier repas chez la
vieille dame
c'est incroyable toutes les pièces sont
en désordre dont sa chambre c'est très
sale et puis ça c'est tout vide des
fourrures et puis tous mes vêtements
pour sortie et puis j'ai très bobo cadre
ici anti des mamelles
mais tout ça et il a enlevé mais en
fouillant la maison avec sa fille elle
récupère finalement la plupart de ces
affaires
tout a été entassés dans cette petite
pièce dont le fameux cadre de la
belle-mère
la famille doit maintenant tout remettre
en ordre ce qui va prendre du temps et
ce soir ce n'est pas encore chez elle
qu'elle dormira mais une fois de plus
chez sa fille
un peu plus tard dans la soirée nous
retrouvons sofia la squatteuse elle a
été provisoirement relogés à l'hôtel par
le samu social
pour violation de domicile cette mère
célibataire risque un an de prison et
15000 euros d'amande
comme elle des milliers de personnes en
grande détresse sont obligés d'accepter
des offres de logements illégal faute de
mieux